it's great to be joined today by
economist Richard wolf professor
emeritus of economics at the University
of Massachusetts currently a visiting
professor at the new school University
in New York City so we've had about a
hundred days of Trump a little more than
a hundred days so far and there have
been scandals and there have been funny
quotes and disturbing incidents etc etc
but the big picture that you've been
observing is that a lot of what we are
seeing now happen sort of at the
systemic level of this administration is
directly tied to the system of
capitalism that we have in the United
States let's start there how can we sort
of conceptualize this well I think what
we have is a system that has come to the
end of a very long period of solid
growth period of reasonable well
performance in terms of the mass of
people despite the crash of the 1930s it
was a system that was able to deliver
rising real wages to the American
working class it thereby persuaded that
class at least for a while that it could
deliver an American dream to everybody a
decent home automobile vacation college
education for your kids and so on that
is over and that stopped around the
1970s when American businesses having
recovered from the loss of face and
power of the Great Depression kind of
took it on themselves exemplified by
Reagan to push back to be able to
reestablish the kind of dominance they
had before the Great Depression and
partly they did that because they always
wanted to they didn't like the Great
Depression taxing them and creating all
these programs for the mass of people
but also they have to compete more and
more with Europeans with Chinese with
Indians and they didn't want to spend
money on social programs they
wanted to make profits for their
businesses you put all that together and
since the 1970s basically two things
have happened one we have replaced
workers with machines computers now
robots and with a kind of frenzy that
says look you've got higher wages but
that's over because you get high wages
we now have an incentive to replace you
with machines and what we can't do in
the way of replacing you with machines
we're going to do by moving our
production to where the wages are much
cheaper
hence the enormous exodus of American
jobs overseas and the bringing of a
growing flood of immigrants low wage
immigrants into the United States when
you put all that together it's over that
is the American dream delivery to the
American working class it's done
corporations don't feel the need to do
that anymore neither political nor can
they afford it in terms of their own
profit plans that can make a fortune of
money by producing for the rest of the
world in the rest of the world and or
with machines and I don't think anybody
has come to terms in the United States
with well I just said let's pick it
apart in a couple pieces if we can I
mean I think that I wanted I observed
during the general election between
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton that
there was a lot of talk about quote
bringing jobs back there was talk about
trade which became something that you
know Donald Trump actually garnered many
supporters for even though there was a
very limited understanding on there and
his behalf of what those talking points
even really meant and not mentioned in
that was the issue of technological
unemployment and historically new
technologies still had a net positive
effect on employment because although
they were destroying the need for some
jobs they were creating brand new
industries
and now it appears that we're in the
phase of a net negative impact
unemployment as a result of automation
neither Trump nor Clinton mention that
and my read of it and I'm curious what
what your sense is is that it's a
lose-lose in other words the first
candidate to mention that will be called
out by the other candidate as basically
having admitted defeat in a sense even
though they would just be stating a sort
of empirical reality is that at least
part of why we didn't hear that
conversation during any of the debates
there in campaign ads at any point I
think that's part of it I would also
argue that while it is easy and
convenient and has a long pedigree to
bash foreigners for giving the jobs at
lower wages to our corporations as if
the corporation's were passive and
victims in all of this that has a long
pedigree attacking technical progress
doesn't and it's very hard for American
politicians or anybody else to figure
out how to say that in a way that
doesn't make you look like you're anti
progress and it also doesn't bring down
on you the rage and anger of the entire
employer class who wants no interference
whatsoever
it is freedom to replace a people with
machines
even though economically speaking it's
always an open question never a settled
matter whether or not when you replace a
working person with a machine this is a
social advance or not if that person is
unemployed if the community where that
person lives is therefore confronted
with that unemployed person with fewer
taxes paid because that unemployed
person is unemployed etc etc when you
start looking at the social consequences
it may very well be an orphan is that a
technological quote/unquote advance is
no advance at all and and that has to be
faced but it has become a political
taboo but you can't go there
so you can have conversations about jobs
leave
but you can't have job a conversation
about automation being a negative impact
situation in our country don't we need
to be thinking of a sort of paradigm
shift in terms of the relationship
between working and income as a result
of this technological issue I mean it's
hard for me to imagine that you know in
the same way that now we laugh when we
say you know all those people who were
saying the automobile will eliminate the
jobs of the horse buggy driver
maybe we should never have developed the
automobile because we would have saved
those jobs I mean it seems sort of silly
now in a sense to think about
suppressing we could argue whether it's
progress or not but what sort of
presented as the advancement of
technology isn't there a different
conversation we need to be having yes I
think so I think in fact it's always
been a kind of a childish debate do you
allow technical progress or do you
prevent it those are not the only
options let's take your example of the
horse and the automobile there was an
alternative between the horse and the
automobile namely a system of mass
transit a system in which the basic
movement of people and goods was to be
accomplished or could have been
accomplished by a combination of rail
traffic of van and bus traffic the whole
notion that you have to add a vast array
of individual automobiles most of which
spend most of their lives on the street
or in a garage is not at all logical or
anything rational at all it's very good
if you're the manufacturer of private
automobiles and those companies made
sure that was the outcome but that was
good for their profits it wasn't some
necessity of technological improvement
and the real question of a rational
society not driven by capitalist profit
would have been to say okay we need to
transport people now let's think through
what the ways are
explain them let's have a mixture of
mechanisms that allows for flexibility
in the face of new technology a rational
way of dealing with these things was
never even on the table because we don't
handle our problems that way we let the
private market profit mechanism roll and
then we spend the following 25 years
persuading ourselves that what happened
through private profit was the best
thing the only thing the necessary thing
text crude rationalization but it's what
passes for politics in our country let's
pick up the conversation there with
economist Richard Wolff and that's
exactly where we will resume on
tomorrow's program
we're continuing our conversation with
economist Richard wolf professor
emeritus at the University of
Massachusetts in Amherst Massachusetts
we we stopped yesterday talking about a
sort of rationalizations that we often
hear particularly retrospectively of
major economic consequence that have
been made in the past let's go back to
what we've seen during the first three
plus months of Donald Trump's
administration and one of your
criticisms that you recently wrote and I
read is that when it comes to Donald
Trump or really any elected official at
the national level that now there's sort
of an Overton Window of what counts as a
valid criticism of policy and they're
usually pretty narrow it could be a
critique of an interest rate or of what
the tax brackets should be or something
along those lines and there's a very
clear avoidance of any broader systemic
critiques this is sort of inherent to
the system we have isn't it absolutely
it's a kind of put your head in the sand
approach that says it's too scary it's
too open-ended to ask the really big
questions is our system broken what
alternative systems could we look at
these kinds of questions have been
written written out written off the
agenda for so long that we've become
accustomed to debating details should
the federal reserve ready to lower
interest rates this month or next month
should should should all of these
elaborate questions that generate papers
with detailed mathematical study this is
all an attempt to keep control of an
economic anomic system that's spinning
out of control that's why it is so
bizarre and why the conventional
make-believe everything's in order that
you would get from a bush or from a
Clinton sounded so hollow to the
American people and rightly so
of course the decision they made to go
with the blustery bully who said in
shoots from the hip and all the rest
that's just a temporary attempt to break
out of what is clearly inadequate even
though what you get in its place is
mostly bravado and then the carrying out
of a very conventional right-wing GOP
program of the sort that the editorial
pages of the Wall Street Journal have
been advocating for decades a fellow new
school professor
Federico Finkelstein has written about
the difference between left and right
wing populism or progressive and
regressive populism have you been at all
surprised at the effectiveness I guess
during the lead-up to the election but
also sort of in terms of the rhetoric
we've heard from the current
administration during their first
hundred or so days it have you have you
been surprised at the effectiveness of
taking what is populist sounding
rhetoric for the people so to speak but
then using the scapegoating of
immigrants and some of these other
tactics you've mentioned in order to
point to particular paths forward should
we be shocked that that has been
relatively effective or is that to be
expected no I believe unfortunately it's
to be expected you know we had 40 or 50
years now of very bland oscillation
between middle-of-the-road Republicans
and middle-of-the-road Democrats each of
them pushed their more extreme
formulations to the side because of the
long history of smashing the left in
America there is Democrats were more
assiduous in squelching their left wing
then the Republicans were in squelching
the right wing they always let that
right wing play in their sandbox that's
why you could have a tea party that's
why it had a place in the Republican
Party as it always has had but you're
basically seeing this collectively
comfortable little disappear people are
too angry people are too clear
their minds that whatever else happens
more of the same is unbearable it is
simply costing too many people too much
of that American Dream elusive as it was
that they can see slipping away from
them and even more so from their kids so
they want at least the rhetoric the
ability to maybe believe even if it's
only for a little while that Trump gets
it that Trump is going to make a
difference he talks like that he
explodes it's a kind of petulance and
upset that that maybe makes other people
feel they're validated in their feelings
like that but let me warn everybody and
mr. Trump if he's listening you're
creating the expectations for some kind
of breakthrough that's going to solve
the problems there's nothing like that
coming down the pike that's what mr.
Trump is having to learn and no matter
how much bluster he does and know how
much theater for the media sooner or
later
masses of people particularly his people
are going to recognize that it's more of
the same more of the same and at that
point the bluster will no longer work
and you have to be a little scared about
where that might go because these people
have invested a lot of Hope a lot of
being different from the mainstream in
America to endorse this Trump if he
turns out to have been a gamer somebody
who's busy feathering his own wealth
nest while the rest of the country
continues basically to go on as it has
the anger that will turn on him will not
be pretty to watch so let's dig into
that idea of being within or outside of
the mainstream I mean you've pointed out
and I think most of our audience sort of
has an understanding that the majority
of Republicans are sort of moderately
right and and most Democrats are sort of
a very very moderate left if left at all
by the standards of particularly of
other countries when you look at at
Donald Trump do you see something that
is actually drastically outside of that
sort of normal spectrum or is it
rhetoric that sounds different but it's
really within that spectrum we've seen
over the last decades very much the
Lottery's it's rhetoric that's a little
different
he has cleverly borrowed from the
Democrats that he's concerned about jobs
in a genuine way that he is going to
bring back the coal industry that he's
going to bring back all those
manufacturing jobs that's the kind of
language that the Democrats have tended
to use guaranteeing social security at
the same time that he talks about tax
cuts is a new wrinkle but that's all it
is when you actually look at what he's
doing it's the same old same old more of
the right for the right wing but it's
basically the old Republican idea you
cut taxes on business in some magic way
that's going to trickle down and make us
all better off you're going to rattle
the Sabre whatever you can make it look
like you're being mr. tough guy you
don't have to live with the consequences
of horribly expensive wars that lasts
forever and that the people don't even
support anymore and then you have a new
one this is not new this is old playbook
a little bit with new possess with new
characters being a little bit outrageous
gives it more of a sense of something
new but no this is a very traditional
pro-business notion of how you solve our
problems deregulate everything put it
back in the hands of private business
let them do their thing
because when businesses make money and
make profits we're all better off the
business community believes that they
always have remember years ago what's
good for General Motors is good for the
United States that mentality is the
mentality that now governs and he's
going to be bold and brash and
in those directions in a way that the
bush type Republican or the Clinton type
Democrat would also do but more slowly
more gently more hedges about with
qualifications but it isn't going to
work just like a mild version isn't
going to work the more extreme version
not only isn't going to work but it's
going to have push backs it's going to
provoke people in ways that are very
very disruptive of the social piece that
we now have but is becoming thinner and
thinner literally with every week last
thing I want to touch on is this idea of
nationalism versus globalism in thinking
about some of the pressing problems on
our planet right now my sense is that
Donald Trump's brand of nationalism is
particularly ill suited to solve the
problems of 2017 in thinking about
climate change for example something
that by no means respect the imaginary
lines on maps when thinking about
technological unemployment which we
spoke about earlier in our conversation
today is your sense that we are in a
moment right now where the nationalist
solutions sort of alluded to or proposed
by Donald Trump are it couldn't possibly
be a worse time for that type of
solution yeah I believe that that's
probably the case I don't take these
kinds of dichotomous approaches all that
seriously the United States has never
given up being a nationalist society
very nationalist it's military posture
is very nationalist its cultural
self-identification is highly
nationalist so on I see our nationalism
is always there I also see that
capitalism has globalized everything
over the last 40 or 50 years and that
the United States had no choice but to
get involved in all of that and then
eventually become a leading player in
all of it so when as a mixture of global
interests and
national pressures and all that's
happening now is that there's a bit of
an adjustment the global picture is
giving more and more power and
importance to places like China and
India and so on and the United States
not used to that it's used to a
globalization in which its dominance
isn't really questioned so it could
indulge a globalization and still do its
nationalist thing that's over X part of
what I meant earlier when I said the
historical success of American
capitalism is over and now it's a time
of cutting back and everybody is making
sure that the cut backbone effect does
not affect them and what you're seeing
is a trump beginning to ride the
nationalist force in the hope of getting
a better international globalization but
that's not in the cards I start
available to the United States we have
neither the wealth nor the power to
force that and consequently it's a
painful adjustment in which you make
lots of noise about rewriting the rules
of international trade which you cannot
do in order to improve your national
situation which has been sacrificed
considerably for the money to be made by
globalization and again mr. Trump can
twist and turn and irate all he wants
these basic adjustments in which the
United States is ratcheting down
becoming less of an important player in
the world economy as India and China and
places like that move up into that
position capitalism doesn't stay still
and it doesn't stay still for United
States any more than it did for anybody
else before or that it will in the
future and this reality again is what is
not being discussed neither by the
bushes nor by the Clintons nor by mr.
Trump who wants to continue living in
the way we can fix all of this just give
me a little more time and I'll take care
of economist Richard Wolff professor
emeritus of economics at my alma mater
the University of Massachusetts in
Amherst
thanks as always for joining me thank
you David look forward to the next time